hey what's up guys chad here from real
life English and learn English with TV
series with another killer English
lesson for you all based on a scene from
the cool TV show Two and a Half Men or
as we say in connected speech two and a
Half Men two in a tuna it's your first
pronunciation lesson for today so to
really make the most out of this scene
I suggest you download the power lesson
which will break down all the new
vocabulary pronunciation
cultural references hope you really
understand all the jokes and I think
you're gonna really love this lesson so
if you have any questions or suggestions
just type them into the comments box
below and we'd love to hear about them
so let's move on to today's awesome
lesson oh yeah
you're right there okay that's Jake's
tutor so could you please go read
somewhere else you got him a tutor yeah
I wanted to graduate high school wise
and the other roadies don't make fun of
him
yeah like anyone's gonna let that kid
work around electricity
okay that's Jake's tutor Sokka okay
that's Jake's tutor so why so the other
roadies don't make me wise and the other
roadies don't make fun of him
make fun of him you got him a tutor you
got him a tutor you got him a tutor you
got him a tutor I wanted to graduate
high school I'm gonna graduate
undergraduate I wanted to graduate high
school don't make fun of him don't make
fun of him don't make fun of him don't
make fun of him
yeah like anyone's gonna let that kid
work around electricity oh hey I'm Stu
the tutor are you Jake no I'm his father
oh I'm Stu the tutor right I'm you been
smoking hot no sir not at all
perhaps you're smelling my cat cap yes
sir he's an outdoor cat okay well uh
come on
as an educator I always tell my students
just to say no to drugs right and you
know how that that saying goes a mind
terrible thing to waste
yeah that's it yeah have you been
smoking hot have you been smoking hot
hey and you know how that that saying
goes and you know how that that saying
goes a mind terrible thing to waste
yeah that's it yeah I'm Stu the tutor
I'm Stu the tutor I'm Stu the tutor I'm
Stu the tutor
have you been smoking hot are you are
you have you been smoking hot
perhaps you're smelling my cat
perhaps you're smelling my cat perhaps
you're smelling my cat perhaps you're
smelling my cat
yes sir he's an outdoor cat yes sir he's
an outdoor cat all right I hope you
really enjoyed those first two parts of
the scene with Stu the tutor pot-smoking
tutor and let's keep this learn and
going by downloading the power lesson
and we're gonna play you out with the
full scene so really focus on your
comprehension how much you understand
how much you've just learned and there's
more to the scene so if you want to
really absorb everything it's a great
way to do that thanks for watching today
if you guys have any suggestions or
questions post them in the comments
below we'd love to hear from people and
you guys have an amazing day I'll see
you later you're right there
okay that's Jake's tutor so could you
please go read somewhere else you got
him a tutor yeah I wanted to graduate
high school wise and the other roadies
don't make fun of him
yeah like anyone's gonna let that kid
work around electricity
oh hey I'm Stu the tutor are you Jake no
I'm his father
oh I'm Stu the tutor right have you been
smoking hot no sir not at all
perhaps you're smelling my cat
cap yes sir he's an outdoor cat okay
well uh come on in
as an educator I always tell my students
just to say no to drugs right and you
know how that that saying goes a mind
terrible thing to waste
yeah that's it yeah this is their brain
on drugs
and uh this is an egg uh Charlie this is
Jake's tutor Stu hey I'm not high man
it's my cat
relax dude we're not cops
oh really he sure looks like the heat
no please make yourself comfortable
Jake your tutors here did you find this
clown Craigslist his ad says he is PhD
big deal I have an ad on Craigslist that
says I have a private plane and a
12-inch penis
guys I got bananas are you hungry Oh
nope numbers about a high pocket
actually this isn't hot anymore
oh no I'll pass uh pita bread hummus um
again no thank you get any more pot not
for $9 an hour I don't I mean I don't
know what you're talking about
Hey Oh Jake Jake uh here let me
introduce you to Stu
he's gonna help you get ready for finals
oh hey little dude ready to have some
mad fun no but I'll take a hot pocket
all right if three hot pockets minus x
equals one hot pocket what does X equal
in my experience X usually equals an
all-night party followed by a headache
and self-loathing
hey man I can't do my job if you're
gonna give away the answers